[Música]
y en directo de américa llegó el momento
de hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero jorge hurtado
jorge en alemania sigue buscando nuevas
alternativas energéticas cuéntanos bueno
andrés si es que el gobierno ahora
anunció que quiere rentar otra terminal
flotante de gas natural licuado para el
invierno del próximo año alemania
asegura que las centrales energéticas
están a un 80 por ciento de su capacidad
y que están listos para afrontar las
crisis de energía con esta nueva unidad
flotante de almacenamiento y
regasificación ya serían cinco las
centrales que el gobierno federal alemán
ha contratado con el objetivo de
diversificar su energía y alejarse de la
dependencia rusa esto dijo el ministro
de economía alemán junto a los
directores ejecutivos de las principales
empresas energéticas ahí escuchemos
information y spies yamaha north swing
uno tenía un volumen de 55.000 millones
de metros cúbicos llegaremos a 25
posiblemente 30 con los proyectos
privados esto significa que si la
construcción avanza rápidamente el año
que viene tendremos una situación
diferente a la de este año y lo que está
sucediendo aquí hay que decirlo es
asombroso que podamos cambiar nuestra
dependencia del gas ruso tan rápidamente
construyendo una nueva infraestructura
que es tan rápido en comparación con la
década que tomó volverse dependiente de
rúsia
'jorge cambiamos de tema pero seguimos
en alemania porque ya empezó el paro de
trabajadores de la aerolínea lufthansa y
se estima que al menos 800 vuelos y unos
130 mil pasajeros se vean afectados por
esta huelga que empezó hoy en alemania y
que afectará principalmente a los
aeropuertos de fráncfort y múnich y
aunque la empresa propuso aumentar 900
euros el salario básico mensual de sus
empleados en los próximos 18 meses el
sindicato argumenta que es insuficiente
y exigen un aumento salarial del 5.5 por
ciento para sus más de 5000 pilotos y
una compensación adicional por la alta
inflación que es generalizada jorge y el
yen cayó a niveles históricos en su
valor respecto al dólar una cifra que no
se veía desde hace 24 años precisamente
de 1998 el yen japonés no registraba un
valor de 140 unidades por dólar en el
mercado de divisas según un analista del
mercado asiático la caída histórica se
debe a la creciente especulación sobre
una mayor ampliación de la diferencia de
tipos de referencia entre japón y eeuu
la reciente devaluación del yen también
se atribuye a las estrictas políticas
monetarias que han tomado los bancos
centrales de eeuu y europa por un lado y
las del banco central japonés por otro
lado debido a que la entidad se ha
mostrado firme en continuar con su
estrategia de estímulos a la economía y
manteniendo las tasas de interés muy
bajas el yen débil beneficia a la
facturación en el extranjero de las
empresas japonesas pero repercuten
negativamente en las cuentas nacionales
al encarecer las importaciones en un
país altamente dependiente de los
productos externos bien vamos ahora a
américa latina' argentina también planea
construir su planta de gas natural
licuado así que bueno esto junto con el
gobierno de malasia según argentina la
construcción de una planta de
licuefacción para exportar gas natural
licuado al mundo y convertirse en una
opción plena de esta crisis energética
el proyecto prevé una inversión de 10
mil millones de dólares que poder
extenderse 40 mil millones de dólares en
10 años aún no se conoce cuál será el
lugar en argentina en el que se
construirá esta planta pero la ciudad de
bahía blanca y la provincia de río negro
son las dos opciones hasta ahora jorge y
el desempleo en la media en américa
latina' vuelve a los números pre
pandemia como es eso bueno según la
organización internacional del trabajo
oit la tasa de desocupación regional
bajó del 87 por ciento que registró en
el primer trimestre del 2022 al 79 por
ciento en el mismo período de este año
sin embargo el organismo también alertó
que el deterioro de las condiciones
económicas globales sigue latente debido
a la elevada inflación generalizada la
guerra en ucrania y los temores de
recesión en grandes potencias económicas
como eeuu el organismo también alertó
que los próximos informes de este año
puede que arrojen un delicado panorama
en el sector laboral pues aunque muchas
personas tienen trabajo su sueldo no les
alcanza para cubrir sus necesidades
porque cuál es nuestra cifra del día 65
dólares por cada 1000 espectadores es el
valor aproximado que la plata forma
streaming netflix planea cobrar a las
marcas por anunciarse a esta medida se
le conoce como el costo por 1000 y
quiere decir que por cada 1000 vistas de
la publicidad las marcas tendrán que
pagar 65 dólares tomando en cuenta que
esta plataforma tiene más de 200
millones de suscriptores a nivel global
y es parte de su estrategia para
diversificarse
tenemos primero pauta en youtube y ahora
pauta en netflix va a ser un poco
complicado mirar de forma continua este
tipo de contenidos que ofrece la
plataforma no probablemente la
suscripción eso sí sea un poco más
barata es lo que han dicho que van a
abrir este nuevo campo para que las
personas pues paguen menos claro jorge
hurtado con información económica
gracias ya viene de santiago lópez en el
debate con aquí en directo médica
gracias por acompañarnos